[Applaudissements]
alors c'est Louis Boyard comme il était
député maintenant il a raconté
dans les rues de Paris un jour il se dit
bon je vais aller voir les hôpitaux
psychiatriques comment ça se passe
il rentre dans un hôpital psychiatrique
le docteur et le reconnaît dit bonjour
monsieur Boyard on visiteurs on sait
très bien pourquoi vous êtes venus faire
de la pub allez venez
quand un fou il est plus fou et bien
c'est simple on fait des tests par
exemple regarder on va faire un test on
va remplir une baignoire pleine d'eau et
à chaque fois on va leur proposer trois
trucs soit une cuillère pour vider la
robe pour vider la baignoire on va leur
proposer soit une cuillère soit une
fourchette soit un seau d'eau et lui
Boyard c'est normal celui qui est guéri
normalement il prend le seau d'eau il
dit non celui qui est guéri retire le
bouchon
[Applaudissements]
un couple au lit la nuit dans le noir et
puis discute ils ont une longue
conversation et sa femme dit à son mari
combien de fois tu m'as trompé oh [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
pardon
et le temps passe une minute de minutes
3 minutes 4 minutes 5 minutes 10 minutes
et lui dit tu dors non je compte
ces deux juifs ils sont à Jérusalem
devant le mur Moché David mocher il est
là il prit du jeu je t'en supplie
j'envoie moi 5 millions d'euros je vais
lancer un petit business j'ai juste
besoin de 5 millions d'euros à côté il y
a David un peu plus simple Dieu je t'en
supplie j'ai besoin juste de 100 euros
j'ai même pas de quoi donner à manger à
mes enfants sans euros et écris plus
fort que David que Moché avec ses 5
millions et dit je t'en supplie 100
euros à un moment je me suis dit attends
tiens prends 100 € laisse de concentré
pour le vrai business s'il te plaît
[Applaudissements]
il a beaucoup de poules non mais tu vas
encore en raconter une autre mais alors
quand est-ce qu'on raconte nous
ce qu'il en a plein
tu vois il se réveille un matin il y a
50 poules qui meurent
d'à côté j'ai un problème je me suis
réveillé le matin il y a 50 poules qui
sont morts comment je peux faire il
écoute ce que tu fais va voir tes poules
ce soir raconte-leur une histoire comme
ça ils vont dormir et personne va mourir
il dit d'accord il va le raconter
l'histoire c'est histoire il était une
fois un prince une princesse
chantez-lui du Jean-Jacques Goldman
chanter de Jean-Jacques Goldman le soir
ça va leur faire du bien ils vont dormir
l'autre il arrive elle a fait un bébé
toute
il part en concert de Jean-Jacques
Goldman il se réveille le matin 200
poules qui meurent
il va voir il dit Rabhi écoutez vous
m'avez donné plusieurs solutions mais ça
marche pas est-ce que vous avez d'autres
solutions
j'en ai mais est-ce que toi tu as cette
poule
Yanis elles sont trop bonnes tu peux
continuer bon alors on est dans une
école en Israël et l'instituteur demande
un des élèves bon dis-moi qui s'est
Moïse alors l'élève lui répond mais
c'est quelqu'un de pas très malin
mais comment tu n'as pas honte de parler
comme ça de notre grand prophète Moïse
en plus tu en abruti parce que quand ils
ont traversé la mer Rouge lui il a pris
à gauche c'est seulement il avait pris à
droite on aurait eu tout le pétrole
le mec qui dit à sa femme chérie ce soir
je te mettrais bien ma [ __ ] dans
l'oreille
et
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une idée qui m'a
je mettrais bien ma vie dans l'oreille
sa femme écoute pourquoi pas mais fais
gaffe quand même que je devienne pas
sourde et là il lui dit bah écoute il y
a pas de danger ça fait 20 ans que je te
le mets dans la bouche tu as jamais
fermé ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
tu as deux doigts
en fait tu chasses tous tes vêtements
[Rires]
est-ce que vous connaissez l'histoire de
l'homme qui avait 5 tonnes
son slip lui allait comme un gant voilà
[Applaudissements]
c'est une catastrophe
les soirées au 06
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un homme qui a un petit kyste à la
gorge et qui va son médecin et médecin
dit bon j'ai pas que des bonnes
nouvelles on peut enlever le kyste le
souci c'est qu'après vous aurez du mal à
déglutir et vous pourrez peut-être ne
plus du tout pouvoir avaler alors
réfléchis après l'assurance est bien
faite on pourra quoi qu'il arrive vous
enlevez le kyste mais derrière après
vous retournez l'intestin et puis vous
pouvez plus vous nourrir par la bouche
mais vous pourrez vous nourrir par la nu
l'anus c'est pas vulgaire
non c'est pas vulgaire c'est l'anus
c'est du latin et alors il réfléchir il
réfléchit bon ok je le fais donc ils
sont enlevé le petit kyste et le matin
au réveil le médecin valoir lui dit ça
va oui ça
petit plats que vous aimez comme ça vous
ça vous permet un peu de vous voilà de
vous relancer petit à petit puis au
moins de rester un peu dans dans le
plaisir est ce que vous voulez
connaissez maintenant de se nourrir ah
oui
bah je vous laisse vous installer qui
sont comme ça
alors il dit vous allez être content
vous avez des carottes
râpées tu vas alors vous me dites j'y
vais
[Rires]
est-ce que ça vous dit que
sa femme l'aime beaucoup alors
on y va
on dit bah écoutez je sais pas ce qu'on
passe au dessert tout de suite ou
peut-être un petit fromage un petit
fromage
j'ai un petit compte voilà apparemment
et puis nous a dit que ça vous ferait
plaisir une petite Charlotte aux fraises
en dessert
allez on y va
alors c'est super il fait super il dit
là est-ce que je peux me proposer un
petit café
mais dis-moi c'est trop chaud mais non
j'entends
tous les jours bravo Michel avec Pierre
également
ça se passe dans un village
c'est une vieille dame très âgée c'est
la doyenne du village qui vit avec son
petit-fils qui est muet
mais un jour elle tombe malade là les
gens du village ils viennent la voir
sauf que c'est le mulet qui ouvre la
porte et elle lui a dit quand il y a
quelqu'un tu me dis qui c'est donc ça
attaque à la porte il va il ouvre la
porte c'est le mécanicien qui arrive
il va la voir
comment ça va ça fait longtemps
ça me fait de la peine de vous voir
malade il s'en va une demi-heure après
il y a le plombier qui arrive et toque
il va avoir le premier il arrive pas on
va voir
c'est le premier dialogue c'est le
rentrer le plombier il arrive
une heure après il y a le maire du
village qui arrive et toc il ouvre le
mieux il voit que c'est le maire la
grand-mère c'est qui
[Applaudissements]